Excuse me, excuse me. Sorry, do you speak English?
No, I don't. Sorry.
Oh! My car's broken down...
...and I wondered if you could tell me where to find a garage.
Yeah. Well, you know, that's wasted on me.
I don't understand what you're saying.
You don't speak any English at all?
Not a word, no.
It's one of those things where I wish I paid more attention in school but...
Excuse me, excuse me. Sorry, do you speak any English?
English? No. What's the problem?
I don't know. I can't understand her.
Hi, my car's broken down and I need to find a garage.
No, I'm so sorry. I didn't understand that at all.
Alright. Well, thanks.
Tell you what, if you go down that way about half a mile, there's a village.
There might be somebody there that speaks English.
I'm so sorry I couldn't be more help.
Yeah. Sorry about that.
Hey, you never know.
Next time you're over, maybe we'll have learned a bit of English for you.
Thanks anyway.
I can speak English.
So can I.